call it a temporary hibernation from
dealing with Piers Morgan quitting in a
strop to field in criticism over how
love Island stars are supported once
cameras stopped rolling
Dame Carolyn McCall is no stranger to
dealing with off-screen drama at ITV the
countless headlines generated by
Phillips cofield's admission of an
affair with a much younger Runner whilst
on this morning saw itv's Big Boss
hauled before MPS questioning whether it
was easier for senior leadership to look
away nobody here on the management board
would ever turn a blind eye to something
as serious as this
as for the fact Dane Carolyn said the
quest
turned 12 times but aside from ruber had
no evidence someone with that kind of
different dynamic in power
that was inappropriate and I think we
would if we had had any evidence or
knowledge of that if Philip had said
that to us we would have acted swiftly
claims that the runner was made to sign
and NDA were denied reports he'd been
paid off explained as a standard payment
after his role was made redundant post
covid and Dane Carolyn was challenged
for dismissing that there might have
been a toxic working environment from
one MP claiming to have spoken to former
staff it's a terrible place to work
daytime in particular is absolutely
toxic they're very disappointing to hear
deeply distressing in my view to hear
dozens of them well could you please
hand those to us and then there was
Tower block Tracy claims that seemed to
shock management denied by ITV that
viewers on occasion had been referred to
in that way in this morning production
meetings indicative perhaps that while
the bosses can have all sorts of codes
of Conduct in place it's hard for them
to actually be across what's happening
further down the food chain never heard
that it's a horrible thing I I
horrible thing to say it's it's not what
ITV would be looking at as a target
audience right we wouldn't describe our
talker audience in that way is it just a
sense that it feels like it's everything
is everybody else's fault you know the
problem
the property accusations of toxicity are
all the fault of disgruntled X employees
was there a disconnect between
management and ITV employees going
forward it will be for the Channel's
independent investigation to try to shed
some light and what's really been
happening behind the scenes Katie
Spencer Sky News